the second messenger cgmp is an
extremely important target for disorders
such as heart failure atherosclerosis
and cardiac hypertrophy disorders
affecting millions
the sgc protein is a site that converts
gtp to cgmp a small molecule controlling
vasodilation
currently very few to no therapies
target the sgc cgmp pathway due to many
unknowns about the protein structure and
qualities
cgmp can not only treat cardiovascular
disorders causing up to 31 percent of
water that's worldwide but also likely
have a role in cancer regulation major
depressive disorder and more
understanding the sgc cgmp pathway with
evolutionary tools is of the utmost
importance to target these deadly
illnesses
this study seeks to first categorize the
protein through models created from
databases and deep learning software
then multiple protein sequence alignment
is used to determine that the hnox
domain of the protein has a high
concentration of conserved residues the
parts of the protein that stay constant
across evolutionary lineages and are
therefore most important for the protein
function
finally a blast genetic sequence
analysis is done to compare htc proteins
such as hemoglobin and it is determined
that stc is a druggable target
after that information is collected a
virtual screening of drug candidates is
done
after reviewing sgt structure it is
visible that it is likely a membrane
protein due to the helix
the hnox domain was first proposed as a
selective membrane may prevent small
molecules from passing through unless
systems are put in place
additionally conserved residues are
concentrated in the h-nox domain so it
would be confirmed that the domain is
functionally important for sgc
finally the hnox domain contains a heme
site which is important for signal
transduction
the only issue is if hemoglobin and sgc
have similar structures as small
molecules may harm hemoglobin a protein
vital for carrying oxygen and carbon
dioxide to and from tissues
by superimposing the two structures of
the multi-aligned viewer it is found the
heme sites occur in different locations
and in fact targeting it would not be
damaging
the hnox domain has some pi pi stacking
one charge center and many hydrophobic
reactions with the outer lining covered
with hydrogen bonds the domain has only
one salt bridge and it is on the edge of
the grid box salt bridges may
destabilize protein structures which can
make it vulnerable to aggregation and
degradation
notably most pi stacking was
perpendicular and not parallel
for the genetic analysis genes that
coexpress and with a high spearman's
correlation are looked at as they may
have similarities or contribute to mmd
both genes rnf213 and
guay1b1 which likely influence sgc were
analyzed
for rnf213 atl z2 has a spearman's
correlation of 0.769
it is a co-actuator for peroxisome
proliferator activated receptor alpha
additionally oas3 regulates expression
of chemokines and interferon repressive
genes
some other co-regulators were ddx-58 and
znf x1 which have a hand in
immunodeficiency hyperinformation and
porto glad cancer
for gu
a1b1
map9 microtubule associated protein ion
has a spearmint correlation of 0.746
and is required for spindle function
mitotic progression and cytokinesis
glrb glycine receptor beta had a
spearmint correlation of 0.703 and
encodes the glycine receptor a
neurotransmitter gated ion channel
finally the pdgfc platelet-derived
growth factor c has experiments
correlation of 0.689
and diseases associated with this gene
are milkers module age-related and
age-related macular degeneration
by gathering this important structural
information drug candidates are proposed
after conducting a virtual screening of
thousands of ligands
drug candidates namely c15 h24n4o
c9h11no and c16h20n4o4
were identified
the drug targets identified can move on
into lab testing on animal models to be
developed further into medications as
there is a lack of fda approved
treatments
finally a combination of evasive
treatment and medication can be used to
reduce the chances of stroke or high
blood pressure
as soluble guanolyl cyclase contributes
to a variety of conditions from
hypertension and mndd to even cancer
further research in drugs targeting
soluble guanolyl cyclase would be
imperative
thank you so much for listening